[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIM O'REILLY: I assume since
you're here that most of you
know who I am.
But just for a little
bit of context setting,
I am going to talk a little
bit about the background
of my company and
why that's relevant.
Because the book
that I've written
is a combination of a memoir
about my time in the technology
industry, a business book, and
an economic call to action.
On the economics, Hal
was my thesis advisor.
The book was-- it was really--
I don't really know that
much about economics.
Although a couple of
people have said, well,
but your instincts are good.
But Hal corrected my
instincts in many, many cases.
But any errors in the
economics portions
are not Hal's responsibility.
But he definitely
would read a passage,
he read multiple times.
He would say, no, you have
to go read this paper.
Oh, you have to go
read this paper.
It was a wonderful
education, and I
hope to continue it as I
go further down this path.
Anyway, so I'm the founder
and CEO of O'Reilly Media.
Most of you probably,
maybe, first knew of us
as a publisher of the
iconic animal books.
This book now--
I think it's still in its
sixth edition, [INAUDIBLE]..
The first edition was in 1985.
It was one of the first
books I ever published.
I think it was in an
edition of 100 copies.
It's gone on to sell, probably,
a million copies since then.
It's still in print
how many years later,
about 32 years later.
But we continue
to be a publisher.
Here's a book that we did
recently with Google on site
reliability engineering,
another book
on hands on machine
learning with Scikit-Learn
and TensorFlow.
These are the kind of thing that
a lot of people in the computer
industry learned of us from.
It's now only about
20% of our business.
But the thing I'm kind
of the proudest of
is the role that I've had in
spreading big ideas about where
the industry is going
and what it ought to do.
So very early in
the '90s, my company
created the first
commercial website,
the site called the
Global Network Navigator.
It was sort of before Yahoo
was the first web portal.
It was also the first
advertising supported site
on the World Wide Web.
The internet was
still noncommercial.
And I did a lot of activism
for the commercial internet
and also for the open
commercial internet.
In the very early
days, for those of you
who weren't around
then, the internet
was a research network.
And I still remember
a conversation
I had with Steve
Wolf, who at the time
was the NSF overseer, National
Science Foundation overseer,
of the internet.
And I said, well, here's
what we're planning on doing.
We're going to build this
website and it will have ads.
But the thing that is
different about the web
is that people come to you.
So we're not going to
be sending out anything
unless people ask for it.
So it's very different.
And he said, well,
you know, the internet
is about research and education.
And if you guys aren't
research and education,
I don't know who is.
So go for it.
And it was a wonderful moment.
Anyway, the later I
organized a meeting
where the term open source
software was widely adopted
and promoted it.
And particularly, told
the story about it
that was bigger than
the political movement
about free software and
being against Microsoft,
by bringing in the story of
why the internet was also built
on top of open source software.
And that was probably
my first experience
of the power of ideas to
change people's minds.
You know, I remember
when I first--
you know, I held
this press conference
at the end of this day that came
to be called the Open Source
Summit.
And I had all these guys
up on a stage, and people
who nobody had ever heard
of, most of them, you know.
And the story I told
was so different--
which had been this
story of free software
is this rebel movement
that wants to bring down
commercial software.
Commercial software is evil.
And I said, hey, if you
guys are on the internet
and you have a domain name-- you
from "The New York Times," you
from "The Wall Street
Journal," or whatever,
this guy over here, Paul
Vixie wrote the software
and gave it away so that that
domain name can be recognized.
Oh, if you send email,
this guy, Eric Allman,
wrote Sendmail, the program
that routes, at that point,
about 70% of all the
email on the internet.
Oh, if you have a website,
it's probably Apache.
This guy Brian
Behlendorf started that.
And it was interesting,
I did about two weeks
worth of interviews.
And in the beginning, what?
The internet is based
on free software?
It was this disbelief.
And it felt a little
bit like you're
trying to push something really
heavy, and it doesn't move.
And then it starts to move.
And within two weeks, it was
just the accepted wisdom.
And that, in a
way, is a backdrop
to the story of the book.
Because I'm trying to change
the accepted wisdom again
with this book.
So anyway, I did it again
with Web 2.0, which is really
the story, for me, of what came
after the dot.com bust, what
was the Second
Coming of the web.
And I had come to
the conclusion,
from thinking about open
source in a very different way
than other people
had, that there
was something very different
about the companies that
survived.
And of course, this
led me down the path
that we're really
moving out of the world
that we knew in the PC era,
where software was an artifact,
to where software
was increasingly
a business process with these
vast cloud applications that
actually had people
inside of them.
And that data was
going to be the source
of competitive advantage.
And that was the heart of
what I talked about Web 2.0.
We also launched something
called the Maker Movement
with a magazine in 2004 called
"Make" and "Maker Faire."
I spent a lot of time in
the last seven or eight
years talking about
how government also
needs to learn about platforms
from the technology industry.
And most recently I've been
talking a lot in the same way
about how to think
differently about AI
and what I call the
next economy, technology
and the future of work.
So a big part of our business
today are conferences.
We just had last week the
O'Reilly AI conference.
This week in New York, this
Strate, The Business of Data.
We're doing a
conference on Jupiter.
Our original, very
first conference
started in '97, the O'Reilly
Open Source Software Summit.
We run Maker Faire.
Something called Food Camp,
which Hal talked about,
which is an unconference.
And then, we have a
platform of our own,
which we started in 2000.
It's called Safari.
It was originally
an ebook platform,
but it's increasingly
a platform,
yes, 40,000 plus e-books,
tens of thousands
of hours of video training, live
training millions of customers.
And it's really a platform
for knowledge exchange.
That's really the
heart of our business.
We're about 20% books,
30% events, and 50%
this online learning platform.
So I spend a lot of time
thinking about platforms
because that really is
the heart of my business.
And I think that
Google also, obviously,
is a platform company.
But I want to spend
a lot of time--
I spent a lot of time
in the book thinking
about digital platforms and what
they teach us about economies.
So I'm going to
come back to that.
So the title of
the book, "WTF"--
you know, now I actually
used this at the White House
Frontiers Conference.
And I was really proud that
I got the White House comms
team to sign off on
a talk called "WTF."
And I did it by kind
of saying, well,
it stands for what's
the future, of course.
But really, the reason why
I wanted to use the term WTF
is because it's a term
of astonishment that
can be the
astonishment of delight
or the astonishment of dismay.
And I think that
really encapsulates
the state of our dialogue
about technology today.
It's the source of enormous
astonishment and wonder,
and it is also a source of fear.
And I started worrying
about this probably
two or three years ago.
I started an event
called The Next Economy
Summit because I was trying
to get ahead of this issue.
How do we think about
technology and the economy?
How do we get technologists
to think about it
and to talk about
it in a way that
doesn't make people afraid?
How do we get
business plans that
are focused on empowering
people and building wealth
for everyone rather
than simply, well, we're
just going to disrupt?
We're going to break things.
You know we're going to make
ourselves really, really rich,
and we're not going to
really worry about what
happens to everybody else.
And that's how the
rest of the world
is starting to see
Silicon Valley.
And in a lot of ways,
the book is an attempt
to address that narrative
head on and to change it.
And to change it by actually
inspiring software developers
and entrepreneurs
to act differently,
to talk differently.
But also to persuade
policymakers
to think and act differently.
So I'm going to try
to give you a few,
a sampling of some of
the ideas from the book.
By the way, back to this
WTF of amazement or dismay,
this is the world of techno
optimism that we all live in.
That's a chart of
life expectancy.
You know, life
expectancy at birth,
pretty much flat, I mean,
there's a few really bad times.
You can kind of see
where it really dropped.
But then suddenly,
this magical thing
happened in the mid 1800s,
when it started to climb.
And then you see additional
countries sort of come
on stream.
This is the modern world
that we have every reason
to be so proud of.
There's a wonderful
site, Our World In Data,
which is this incredible
collection of graphs
and narratives about
the way that technology
is making the world better.
So I'm standing
in front of this.
Sorry about that, guys.
So I guess I'll
be back over here.
But everyone is
not equally happy.
We see Brexit,
the rise of Trump.
And here's this WTF, you know,
on the "Daily Telegraph,"
you know?
And the question is-- this
is not the first time when
we have had this kind of upset
and worry about technology.
This is an etching about
the Luddite rebellion.
Now one of the things I learned
that many of you may not know
is that Ned Ludd did
not actually exist.
He was not the leader
of the Luddites.
He was a mythical figure that
this particular revolution,
in 1811, 1812, cited.
He was somebody
who apparently had
smashed a loom 30 years before.
And they went down his
story, and they kind of
carried the banner of Ned Ludd.
But here's the point.
These guys were right to be
afraid, because the ensuing
years were pretty bad.
When you think about the
early years of the Industrial
Revolution and William
Blake's description
of the "dark, satanic mills,"
this was not a good time.
But those weavers
could not imagine
the wealth of modern society.
They couldn't imagine
that their descendants,
that this production, this
mass production of fabric
would produce a world in
which their grandchildren
and great grandchildren
would have more
clothing than the kings
and queens of Europe
did at the turn of the 18th
century, or the 19th century,
rather.
They couldn't imagine that
their descendants would have
fruit in the middle of winter.
They couldn't imagine
that we would actually
build skyscrapers
half a mile high,
that we dig a tunnel
under the English Channel
to France, that we'd go
into space, that we'd
fly through the air.
All these things are amazing.
And they couldn't imagine
that their descendants would
find so much meaningful
work bringing
all these things to life.
And so one of the questions I'm
asking in the face of today's
world of AI and all
these new technologies
that we're being
told again and again
are going to destroy jobs, what
is our failure of imagination?
What are we not able to imagine?
And what world are we not able
to paint for our grandchildren
of the world to come?
And so one of the things
that I start the book with
is a little excursion into this
idea of fitness landscapes.
And evolutionary
biology is this idea
that genes contribute to
the survival of an organism.
You can think about this as
kind of a landscape of peaks
and valleys.
And organisms evolve
towards the peaks,
which are adapted to their
environment, or they die out.
And so there is this the
concept of a local maximum.
And a lot of what
happens is society
and companies get comfortable
with this local maximum,
and they don't know
how to move on.
And often the only
way to move off of it
is actually to go backwards.
You have to go down.
And that's why we have this
cycle sometimes of revolutions,
of companies fall apart.
Anyway, fitness
landscapes are dynamic.
When conditions are stable,
you can kind of just
stay there, but if things
are changing, not so good.
And of course, we have
radically changing conditions.
Climate change is
a great example.
If you look at the failure of
many civilizations in the past,
they were driven
by climate change.
We may face a great deal
of pressure on our fitness
landscape today as
a result of that.
And technology also has
a fitness landscape.
In my career, I watched
the fitness landscape
of the personal computer,
the big data and AI world
that Google lives in.
The smartphone landscape
dominated, just
really broken open by Apple.
And now it's sort of a
subject of fierce competition
between Google and Apple.
And what's really
interesting when
you think about what happened,
why was it hard for Microsoft
to get to the big data world?
Well, they had too much--
this is a perfect illustration
of the fitness landscape.
They had a business model
that really worked for them,
and they fought--
there were people who
were saying that we
got to get with the internet.
And they were kind of like, no,
we have to preserve Windows.
And that was their priority.
And I think it's something that
we always have to think about.
The dominant companies
tend to be slow to adapt.
So the thing is that
one of the problems
is that those dominant
companies tend
to extract too much of the
value from the ecosystem
for themselves.
You know, Microsoft basically
put other companies out
of business.
They would come down to Silicon
Valley, meet with VCs, and say,
you can't invest there because
we're going to do that.
And this is a real risk, I
think, for Google as well.
It's really, I think, a mistake
to think about just value
for users.
Because Google will make a case,
well, we're doing this thing,
and it's better
for our customers.
But you actually have to think
about the whole ecosystem.
And in particular, you have
to think about the ecosystem
of developers.
People went to Linux
and the World Wide Web
because there was no room left
in the Microsoft ecosystem.
They went somewhere.
They didn't think they were
going to go make a lot of money
over on the web.
They just went, this is cool.
This is interesting,
and it's free and open.
And that sort of
"free and open" was
what gave birth to
the new "fitness"
landscape, the small mammals
coming up from the valleys
into this new fitness peak.
So again, it's always
something to worry about
if you're as dominant as
Google Is, is to think about
are we making enough value for
these developers who are part
of our ecosystem, these
people who are creating
on top of our
platform and making it
a rich, stable ecosystem?
Or are we basically saying we
have to do that for ourselves?
I had that experience
many times with Microsoft.
It was, like, oh,
that's a great idea.
We have to do that, sorry.
So in our political landscape,
we're seeing this same thing.
We've had this idea that by
making a small number of people
very, very, very wealthy,
it would trickle down
to the rest of society.
It hasn't entirely worked
that way, and guess what?
The people are moving
somewhere else.
They're saying, we don't
like that consensus
about how to run the world.
We're going to do
it differently.
They may even be wrong.
And in my opinion,
not even a may.
But there's a real serious
risk that the conditions
that we at Silicon Valley
have used to thrive
are going to change
radically because
of the political environment.
And so one of the key pieces
of advice I give in my book
is just to remember that a
successful ecosystem creates
opportunity for everyone.
And this, obviously, was brought
into the political discourse
by Thomas Piketty's
book, "Capital,"
in the 21st century,
where he really addressed
this question of inequality and
got everybody talking about it.
There have been other people.
Joe Stiglitz had written
about the 99% versus the 1%
before Piketty came out.
And that almost caught.
But when Piketty's
book came out,
it was, like, everybody
started talking about it.
And so I decided to take
a technological angle
on all this, to kind
of tell this story
from the point of view
of the tech industry.
Because there's a lot of people
talking about it as economists.
And in a lot of ways,
the heart of the book
is a series of stories about
what the great technology
platforms have to tell us
about the future of business
and the economy.
And the first is this
point I've already
made, that platforms
have to work
for all their participants,
not just for the users
or the platform owner.
There's also the point that
platforms today are no longer
just about the digital, right?
There enmeshed in
the real world.
You think about Uber or Lyft.
This is really this
system, you think
about this huge,
algorithmic system.
And sure, there are people at
the end points of all the touch
points of Google, people who
are uploading YouTube videos,
or they're clicking on links
or they're creating web pages.
But boy, it becomes really
obvious that human beings are--
as Sean McMullen the
science fiction author,
are souls in the great machine--
when you have these cars
dispatched by algorithm
with drivers, you have
this swarming marketplace
where people are doing
things in the real world
at the beck and
call of algorithms.
So we have to start thinking
about this interpenetration
of the digital into all
of our business processes,
into all of our world
as we effectively
take the principles that we've
been practicing in the purely
digital realm for the
last couple of decades
and start to see them show up
everywhere in the real world.
So it becomes even
more important.
And the third key point is
that the fundamental function
of every technology is
that it augments people
so they can do things that
were previously impossible.
We couldn't fly through
the air, and now we can.
And so when you think about
what AI is going to do,
there's a strong
narrative that it's going
to put people out of work.
And instead, I think
the narrative--
we need to be seeking out
the narrative of what will it
let us do that we can't do
today, that will be wonderful,
that will make us full
of that WTF of delight?
And we have to tell
that story powerfully.
And we have to believe it.
And we have to build
products and startups that
deliver on that promise.
So there is kind of
this interesting thing
that, of course, the WTA
of delight becomes banal.
I still remember once landing
in Sydney airport in Australia.
And they had this giant mural.
And I wish I could find the
name of the photographer,
because it's long gone now.
But it was thousands
of people turned out
to see the first airplane
come to Australia.
And it was just these
faces looking up in wonder.
It has been a voyage
of many months,
for many people that emigrated.
And then it's, like, they're
connected to the world.
And it's, like, oh, my god.
And now you think about
airlines, oh, my god.
So the WTF of wonder actually
later became the WTF of dismay.
And we have to
watch out for that.
But that source of
wonder is so important.
But this idea of augmentation,
let me kind of come back
to Uber and Lyft.
When you think about
that experience,
there's a couple of things.
The first is this magical
experience, which goes away
because you get used to it.
Wow, I don't have to call a taxi
company and hope they show up.
I don't have to stand out on
the street corner and wave
and know they're all full,
or there's nobody there.
I can summon a car.
I'd get an estimate of when
it's going to be there.
And I walk out, and
it just comes, magic.
Realizing the capability
that was hidden in our phones
to match people in a real
time-matching marketplace,
right?
But also-- and this is one of
the things that lot of people
don't understand
about Uber and Lyft.
It's like taxi companies go,
well, we have to have an app.
But we hate this idea
of part-time drivers
who just show up and
don't have licenses.
And you go, well, guess what?
All the parts of that
business model work together.
It's because you have
those part-time drivers
that you can have three minute
pickup times all the time.
You don't run out
of cabs, right,
because they're
harnessing the marketplace
in this new algorithmic way.
And the reason they can do
that is because the drivers are
augmented with this new
cognitive augmentation
called Google Maps.
There are ways, it's
built now into the app.
People don't have to have
the knowledge of the streets
and monuments of London.
They can just turn
on the app, and it
says, turn right here, right?
And literally, the
knowledge is a test
where you are a human GPS.
You're like a mentat out
of Frank Herbert's "Dune,"
where, literally, they give
you two points in London
and you have to recite
the turn by turn
to get from one to the other.
And now you don't
have to do that.
So that that
cognitive augmentation
also is going to make
new things possible.
Just like the steam
shovel or the steel girder
or the steel beam in
the physical world,
cognitive augmentation allows
people to do new things
that they couldn't do before.
So I also talk a
lot about the fact
that these systems are
algorithmic systems, at least
today.
They infused with AI.
But these algorithmic
systems have
a sort of a fitness function
or an objective function.
And I want to talk about
that in the context
of the economy in a bit.
Because I think there's
real significance
for society, the economy, and
the future of the human race
in the algorithms that we
are building into our future,
and I'm gong to talk
about that in minute.
So a bunch of my writing on the
topic that's not in the book
you can find at the site
WTFEconomy.com as well as
some content that's in the book.
Anyway, come back to this
notion-- a platform must create
more value than it captures.
That's been kind of
the heart of what
we try to do it at O'Reilly.
We invited in our biggest
competitors into our platform
when we launched it.
We continue to think
about how do we make money
for them as well as for us.
I think Google should--
I've loved what Hal has done
with the Google economic impact
reports, because it's starting
to tell a story which should
be told by every
business in America,
every business in the world.
Which is, how are we creating
value for other people,
for others, not
just for ourselves,
all this financial reporting
that's just about wow,
look how well
we're doing, great.
There are companies
that are doing well
by making other people do badly.
And we have to actually have
a system-wide accounting
of what people are putting in
and what they're taking out.
And the alternative, if you are
a Google-like company, where
you are a systematic
platform company,
is you become a
regulated utility.
Because if people
say, wow, you are not
looking after your ecosystem.
Well, we'll look
after it for you.
So I think that's something
you guys should be very worried
about.
I want to kind of come back.
I've talked about a
lot of this already.
But this is something out of
the book, this notion of what
I call a business model map.
A business model is the way
that all the parts of a business
work together to
create customer value.
And I first was
introduced to this concept
by some consultants called Dan
and Meredith Beam back in 2000.
And they actually used the
example of Southwest Airlines
versus hub and spoke airlines.
And they kind of
went through how
all the parts of
Southwest's business
actually make them
very different
than the other airlines,
even though they're
all in the airline business.
So they don't forward baggage.
They don't have assigned seats.
This actually is different.
And so Google and Facebook, both
in the advertising business,
but you have very different
parts of your business model.
So for example, with
Google, right, your customer
succeeds when they come to
Google, get what they want,
and go away.
So your success is aligned with
people leaving Google, coming
and leaving.
Facebook's success is
aligned with having
people come and stay.
And that's a huge difference
in your business model,
and a huge lever if
you are competing
with Facebook, for example.
Because you have
to say, oh, wow,
we have to find
more reasons to get
people to go away and not to
get people to come and stay
with us.
Because then you're
playing on Facebook's turf.
And Sun Tzu says, attack
your enemy where he is strong
and you are weak--
I mean, where he is
weak and you are strong.
So anyway, back to this--
I tried to draw a model of Uber.
Because it seemed to me to be
kind of a template for what's
starting to happen
in the economy.
We have these companies
that are platforms.
They're not just
traditional companies.
They're replacing
ownership with access.
And they've got this marketplace
managed by an algorithm,
matching up passengers
and drivers.
So there's a bunch of things--
workers supplying their own
cars, independent contractors,
that are really
part of this story.
And this augmented workers
idea that we talked about,
magical user experience.
So all of these
things go together.
And one of the things
we have to understand
as we think about
technology and the economy
is what things go together
in our business model?
What things belong and what
things fight against it?
And so for example,
at O'Reilly, one
of the things that we realized
that made us able to transition
from being a publishing
company to be a conference
company and an online
learning company
was that we realized
we were really
a company that was
about connecting people
who knew something
with people who
wanted to learn it from them.
And so we were able to evolve
how we did that because we
really understood that.
Whereas a lot of our
competitors, most of them
no longer really in
the business very much,
they just thought their job was
to capture knowledge into books
and put it on shelves.
So anyway, I spend
some time, really,
trying to think through business
models and how they work
and how they're changing
in the age of the platform.
I've talked a little bit about
this thick marketplace idea.
House student
Jonathan Hall, who's
the chief economist
at Uber, turned me
onto this book, Alvin Roth's
"Who Gets What and Why,"
which is really
about how do you make
a successful
matching marketplace,
which is at the heart of so many
of the great platforms today.
And so that kind of
led me to this path
of thinking about marketplaces.
But then, again, I talked about
this augmented worker concept.
But there's a really
key part of it,
and that is really something
I call the arc of knowledge.
When we think about how do
we communicate knowledge,
we first spoke it to each other.
And then we wrote it
down, things like maps.
And you think about the first
iterations of online maps.
They were kind of reproductions
of printed maps, just
online, which was kind of nice.
And then you got
maps and directions.
And you go all the way
up to automated vehicles,
and you see that the knowledge
disappears into a service.
And that seems to
me to be a key point
to remember when you think about
how are we augmenting workers.
We're basically building
these cognitive augmentations
that will just
disappear into services,
where you don't necessarily
need to know in advance things.
You know, this is
already so true.
We were talking over lunch about
how, oh, yeah, some technique.
How do you learn it?
You go to YouTube, and
you watch the video.
And before long, maybe we will
be in the place like Trinity
in "The Matrix,"
where we can say,
I need to know how
to fly a helicopter.
Remember, she downloads
the knowledge.
But even without that, we can
have these augmented devices
that capture and
share human knowledge.
So when I think about AI,
that's my starting point--
is that it's a tool
for human augmentation.
It isn't this radical
discontinuity,
this machine from
the future that's
going to make humans obsolete
any more than machines
of the industrial
era were somehow
going to make humans obsolete.
Yeah, sure, yeah, we're
not as strong probably
as most of our--
even if we work out a
lot, we're probably not
as strong or as
fit as someone who
worked every day on the farm
or doing [INAUDIBLE] work.
I still remember going to Hawaii
once and huffing and puffing up
over some hill.
And it was like, oh, yeah,
the ancient Hawaiians,
it took them about 20
minutes to go up and over
to the other waterfall.
It took us two hours.
Yeah, we're not as fit,
but we are more capable.
If you've ever read
"Guns, Germs and Steel,"
you know it opens to
this wonderful passage.
You get all these questions.
A guy in New Guinea saying, you
know, you guys are so stupid.
If I took you in the jungle,
you'd be dead in two weeks.
How come you have all the cargo?
And that is, in fact, the
question of our civilization.
It's, like, we are
making ourselves smarter,
stronger, faster, better.
And that should be
how we frame and how
we think about what we're doing
with technologies, not disrupt.
It's not destroy.
It's not eliminate.
It's empower.
It's lift up.
It's make things possible.
So technology is our superpower.
And this is another one of the
charts from Our World in Data
of the number of people
in the world living
in absolute poverty.
And you watch that
incredibly steep decline.
And that's wonderful.
But inequality is
our kryptonite.
And this is from the
we are the 99% story.
We have to confront that.
We have to think about it,
particularly as a society,
but also as an industry.
So one of my
interesting questions
that I try to explore
in the book is,
what keeps us from creating
prosperity for everyone?
And here's the answer.
And this is the connected
taxicab circa 2005.
It's, like, wow, we had
connected taxi cabs.
What did we do?
We put a screen
in the back where
people could look
up information,
where they can watch ads.
And we totally missed--
even though, actually,
Sunil Paul, in 2000,
had written a series
of patents about what
would be possible if you
tried to connect cars
with smartphones.
Actually, they weren't
even smartphones, but
with GPS and phones.
It was just too early, right?
So there was this sort
of cognitive filter,
this cognitive blindness.
You were actually sort
of framing blindness,
may be the right way to say it.
Where we framed the world
in a particular way,
and we couldn't see
what was possible.
And I think this is
a critical problem.
And I've watched it
throughout my career.
In 2000, I led this protest
against Jeff Bezos's one click
patent.
And we went and we looked--
Jeff kind of worked with
me to try to turn it around
from a PR point of view.
One of the things
we did was we funded
a startup called Bounty Quest,
which looked for prior art
on one click shopping.
And we couldn't find it.
Because, basically, it was sort
of unthinkable at the time.
People were afraid to put
their credit cards online.
They had the shopping
cart metaphor.
They kind of
understood the world.
It was very much like this
connected taxi cab circa 2005.
So the reason I tell you
that story, actually,
and here's another one.
It's, like, I asked Tony
Fidel, why didn't you guys
do the connected speaker?
And he says, well,
can you imagine
if people had thought
Google is listening to me?
Somebody had to make
that possible first.
Because there was just this--
because of Google's particular
position in the market,
you couldn't be the first mover.
But you still have to understand
that these cognitive shifts do
happen where people believe
that something else is possible.
But more than that, I want to
actually take that thinking
to the political and
the economic realm.
And this is where I start to
get out of my depth in the book.
Maybe it's just a
thought experiment.
But maybe, just maybe,
it's something that's
really worth thinking about.
And this is the
beginning of, actually,
an argument that runs through
a central section of the book.
And it's about sort of AI
and algorithmic systems
and their relationship
to human society.
And I ask the question,
what if strong AI bears
the same relationship
to today's narrow AI
as multicellular life does to
its single-celled forebears?
Now right now we keep
thinking that we're
going to create a strong AI.
Maybe it'll be 15,
20 years from now.
Maybe it's be 50.
Maybe it'll be 100.
But it'll be like us, a
single, self-aware being.
And I wonder if instead
it's a collective being.
And it turns out
that that is what
happened in this prokaryotic
to eukaryotic cell transition.
Because it turns out that
there's this thing that Lynn
Margulis in 1967-- actually, I
think it was originally, again,
in [INAUDIBLE] in 1905
that first proposed it.
But she picked it up
in '67 and actually
proved it over a lot of years
of being ridiculed and pushed
back on.
And it was this idea
that multicelled
organisms actually incorporated
bacteria into them.
So it turns out, and
was later substantiated
by genetic evidence, that
mitochondria in our body
are actually bacteria that came
and lived inside of us, right?
Same thing with
chloroplasts and plants,
they have totally
different genetic material
than the nucleus of the cell.
And so in a similar way,
I started thinking, well,
what if we are somehow like
that with our computers?
And of course,
biological symbiosis
doesn't start with
that symbiogenesis
that Lynn Margulis talked about.
There's also this
increasing knowledge
of the microbiome, how we
are really a colony organism.
Ed Yong in his wonderful book,
"I Contain Multitudes" says,
all zoology is really ecology.
When we look at beetles
and elephants, sea urchins
and earthworms,
parents and friends,
we see individuals driven by
a single brain and operating
with a single genome.
And this is a pleasant fiction.
You know, we're legion, he
and Walt Whitman, "I am large.
I contain multitudes."
So think about this
in humans, too.
When we talk about
unsupervised learning
as the holy grail of AI,
I go, yeah, you know,
humans have some amount
of unsupervised learning.
We have a shit ton of
supervised learning.
We learn our language
from our parents.
Everything we know that makes us
able to do the kinds of things
that we do here at Google,
we were taught by somebody.
And then, on top
of that, yes, we're
able to do
unsupervised learning.
But we have a long
way to go, I think,
in the supervised
learning of this organism
before we can kind
of even expect to see
it start to do unsupervised.
It's not like you start,
necessarily, there.
So
Thinking about
this as a metaphor,
I started thinking about--
I've been really thinking about
this for the last 10, 15 years.
How increasingly, we're
all, all of humanity,
is being woven into this new
global mind, this super AI.
And we're seeing in
things like fake news
kind of the equivalent of
our neuroses, the equivalent
of bad ideas.
They spread
incredibly quickly now
and are adopted by
millions of people.
And then encoded further into
the systems that we build.
So we're at this really
interesting phase of symbiosis.
And we have to come
and understand it.
And we think that our
emergent proto-AIs are also
compound beings,
just like we are.
What would we do differently?
How would we think about
them, and what do we
know about them today?
And there's a lot
of fear of some kind
of future, hostile AI.
And I go, well, if there is
one, we are already teaching it.
And what are we teaching it?
So when you think
about this further,
we're seeing this
compound being.
We see the rise of
specialized chips,
which is actually a pretty
interesting imitation
of neuroscience.
But here is a great one.
Here's one of the mitochondria
inside the Google Brain, right?
And here's the thing, we've even
defined in our legal system,
starting in 1888, we said
that there's this thing called
a corporate person.
It's really just this
collective organism.
That was the case called
"Consolidated Silver Mining
v. Pennsylvania."
"Under the
designation of person,
there's no doubt that a
private corporation is
included in the 14th Amendment.
Such corporations are merely
associations of individuals
united for a special purpose."
Right?
So a special purpose organism--
and guess what?
We now have these
special purposes
organisms are increasingly
digital, increasingly quick,
increasingly algorithmic.
We're making these
special purpose organisms.
And what are we
asking them to do?
And I believe that one
of the things that we
have to come to grips with
is that, in some ways,
these AIs that are our
children are already
ruling human society.
And we have to ask
ourselves, what
is the motivation
of this new species?
Now this is obviously
kind of out there.
But think about it.
How does Google decide
what it's going to do?
Well, we actually--
we collectively,
starting with Larry
and Sergei and you
know all the early founders, but
people like Hal and all of you,
have actually put thoughts
into this shared Google brain.
You've trained it.
You've taught it.
And you've taught it that it
should optimize for relevance.
And this is this sort of master
organizing objective function
of everything that
Google does, whether it's
in search or advertising.
It's, like, find the thing
that people are looking for.
So you've kind of built
this special purpose
organism that has these goals
built into it, baked into it.
And those goals actually
now exist independently
of any of the people
who created it.
Again, it will die, just like
a biological organism will
die under certain conditions.
But it doesn't actually
depend on any individual cells
to remain.
We've all been told that
our bodies can completely
recycle, be completely different
cells every seven years,
I think it is.
And same thing-- all the
people could cycle out,
and this organism would continue
with the same programming,
with its continual,
adapting program.
So think about that.
So Google, relevance, and
Facebook, engagement--
and we saw with
Facebook and fake news
how that can go wrong.
And it basically
reminds me, I guess,
of the story of Mickey Mouse
and the broomsticks in Fantasia.
I mean, all of these systems,
we tell them what to do,
and we set them going.
And they do what
we told them to do.
But we don't necessarily
quite understand it.
And this is the
story that comes out
again and again in Arabian
mythology with genies.
And you told them--
this is actually an
illustration by Edmund Dulac
from the 1,001
nights, that is sort
of a rising of great power.
But what's it going to do?
It's going to do
what we told it.
But maybe we didn't
understand it.
We didn't tell it quite right.
Mark thought that by building
this social platform that
was focused on engagement, he
would build real community.
And then he found
instead that we
have created this monster,
which he is now trying
to bring back under control.
That's actually part
of the experience.
So many years ago, a
friend of mine said to me,
this was in the early days
of Macintosh programming,
he said the art of
debugging is figuring out
what you really told
your program to do
rather than what you
thought you told it to do.
And we are, right now,
engaged in that process
with these new digital
gens that we have created.
We are saying, are they
doing what we meant?
Are they doing what
we told them to do,
but wasn't quite what we asked?
And how do we fix that?
That's what you do
every day at Google.
You try to actually
go, yes, is it
doing what we really
meant it to do?
And now, my question is,
are we doing that same thing
in our broader society?
Because here's the
data that we see
that is at the heart
of this economic unease
that we're facing, which is
that this wonderful gift,
the WTF of amazement
is that productivity
has continued to go up.
If you look, this is from
1945 up through 2015.
And it's pretty, my
god, it's a graph
that Ray Kurzweil
would be proud of.
It's just up and to
the right, right?
And then you see this
divergence starting around 1970s
of real family income.
Somehow that
productivity was not
getting through, not being
distributed to ordinary people.
Now there's a lot of reasons
why that may have gone wrong.
And people like Hal
study this, and his ilk,
this is what economists do.
And I'm not saying what I'm
proposing is the only cause,
but I think it is one of them.
And that is this.
Here's another one of
these AIs, these proto-AIs,
that we tell it what to do.
And is it really
doing what we think?
And this is the Equinix
NY4 data center,
which is one of the hearts of
our financial trading system.
And this is kind of the
Skynet of the story.
Because ultimately, we
told our financial system
what its objective
function should be.
Milton Friedman in 1970 wrote an
article in "The New York Times"
called "The Social
Responsibility of Business
is to Increase Its Profits."
That businesses should not think
about anything other than that.
And if they did that, they
would pass along the profits
to the shareholders
and the shareholders
could make up their own mind.
This is a perfectly
reasonable thesis,
just like some of the theses
that you've put into your code.
But when you build
code, and you actually
do that debugging
process-- you say,
did it do what I asked it to do?
And we have to ask ourselves,
when we said optimize
for share price, in particular--
optimize for profits,
and the profits, this
proxy is the share price
of companies-- optimized
for that, not for people.
Oh, yeah, if it makes sense,
outsource the factories.
If it makes sense,
gut that community.
because your master
fitness function,
the wish that we expressed
to the genie we built
was make my share price go up.
And this is,
actually-- there are
a lot of people in the
financial industry who are
starting to take note of this.
I mean, Larry Fink, who runs
BlackRock, the largest asset
manager in the, world
has been railing
about stock buybacks, Warren
Buffett questioning them.
There's a number of books.
This one "Makers and
Takers" is really good.
Another one there,
"Golden Passport,"
about how Harvard
Business School kind of
wrecked the economy.
But so this idea that the
financial markets, which
are really meant to
support the human economy,
have become this extractive
platform that basically
says, no, give the money to us.
And we have to
actually reverse that.
And that's when I
want to come back
to this story about
the little screen
in the back of the taxicab and
the failure of imagination.
Because it's very
hard for us to imagine
a completely different world.
So when we talk
about tax reform,
it's like we'll push this
rate up and that rate down.
That's not how it happens.
The great revolutions
are ones where you really
imagine the world anew.
And we're good at
that in technology, we
think about that all the time.
And we need to do it also
in the world of politics
and the economy.
And we have done that before.
When the founders of this
country got together and said,
we're going to try to
build a new country
with a new set of ideas.
You know, oh, my god,
there is that famous story
about King George.
When George Washington stepped
down, so basically, originally,
when he won the war,
all the Europeans
expected that George
Washington would
become the king of America.
And George III is
reported to have said--
he went back to
his farm instead.
And King George said, if he has
done that, he is the greatest
man the world has ever seen.
It was this unthinkable thing.
You know?
So much more unthinkable than
Uber was to a taxi company,
or that one click was
to an ecommerce site.
It was amazing!
And we can do that.
So if we are entering a
world where AI can do so much
more of the jobs that we
do today, we should not
be content to say,
well, we'll just kind of
keep feeding the current system
Cory Doctorow, the science
fiction writer, had this great
statement on social media
recently, where he said
economists use equations
to justify the divine
right of capital,
the way that court astrologers
used the stars to justify
the divine right of kings.
And you know, whether
it's true or not,
it's true in the
spiritual world.
This idea that we basically
justify the system
as it is rather than imagining
the system as it could be.
And I see this
enormous opportunity
to make a more
prosperous world with all
of these technologies we have.
So what makes me
hopeful is first of all
that when we build these
algorithmic systems,
we can start to see
ourselves better.
Bias encoded and taken
to scale becomes visible.
When we have been arresting
blacks at a much higher rate,
and not seeing it, it's just
kind of in the woodwork.
We go, well, it's human
bias, you know, sure.
But then, all of a
sudden, when you're going,
wow, we're baking it
into the algorithms,
because we're using
these training
datasets that are based on
decades of biased policing.
We can suddenly see it.
We can fix it.
We can debug our society.
So that's the first thing,
this whole engagement,
this digitalization
of our world,
is going to help us understand
our world and make it better.
And the second
thing, AI is going
to help us to understand
more deeply what is human.
And it can create
new kinds of beauty.
I love this statement from the
37th move of the second game.
It was a fan who, he
talking about it, he says,
it's not a human move.
I've never seen a
human play this move.
It's so beautiful.
You know, this idea that
something new that we have not
imagined can be beautiful,
that it can not be something
to be afraid of, that it can
be something wonderful-- that's
the world that I think we
in the technology industry
should be committed to creating.
And finally, I just
want to remember
that it isn't technology
that wants to eliminate jobs.
My friend Nick Hanauer
said, "Technology is
the solution to human problems.
We won't run out of work
until we run out of problems."
So I think we all,
in our industry,
have to commit ourselves
to solving human problems.
Make it work.
Make the world a better place.
So that's the master
design pattern
of technology and, really,
the message of the book.
Our job is to augment people
so they can do things that
were previously impossible.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Well, Tim,
thanks so much for coming.
I'm really excited
to read your book.
I was just curious,
as someone who's
been in the publishing
and content industry
for the past 20
years, why, when you
think about transmitting these
ideas about the future, why
you chose to do it in
the form of a book?
When there's lots of different
tools out there today.
And so, as somebody who's
thought a lot about this,
I'm just kind of curious.
Like, why did you choose to
canonicalize it in this form?
TIM O'REILLY: That's
a really good point.
Actually, probably
the trigger was
that I had been
running this event
called The Next Economy Summit.
And I was trying to
get on Michael Krasny's
show, the local PBS show.
And I just was having
a lot of trouble.
And then somebody who had
written a book that I really
didn't respect
appears on the show.
And I'm, like, damn.
For a certain kind of
intellectual discussion,
it is still the
little entry card.
I couldn't get in this room
without the Google entry card.
And writing the book gets you
discussed by the policymakers.
Because that's the thing,
all these people who
should be deeply
involved in the digital
because it's the center
of our world, nah.
I mean, this is a
book that I can send.
I can put it in front of a
policy maker, have them read,
have the think tanks
in DC talk about.
I can give talks there
because I wrote a book.
And otherwise, I'm some
weird new media guy.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And of course, you've
been a publisher for 30 years.
TIM O'REILLY: Yeah,
which is ironic.
And actually, I didn't
publish it myself.
I actually went to one of the
traditional business publishing
companies, because
again, it's just
this credentialing function.
AUDIENCE: Tim, excellent set
of hypotheses, but one of them
is the core of the
actors have changed.
Obviously, we talked about
big things, like Uber today,
they started as
very small things.
Do you have any conclusions you
draw as to whether innovation
is possible as
things get, quote,
"more multi-cellular" at
the small stage, garage
stage, middle start up stage?
Or would you be
thinking that, as data
gets a gravity of
its own, that we're
going to see a return to
bigness for its own sake--
TIM O'REILLY: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --exponential
for startups in this world?
TIM O'REILLY: Well, I
do think, first of all,
the power of ideas is profound.
Even if a startup
doesn't survive,
it can actually place a
new idea into the world.
And that idea can be taken up.
And that is why create
more value than you capture
is sort of part of my motto.
I just believe, yes, in the
end, we're all going to fail.
I've often quoted this
wonderful poem of Rilke, "what
we fight with is so small.
And when we win,
it makes us small.
What we want is to be defeated
decisively by successively
greater beings."
He's talking about
wrestling with the angels.
And I think, so yes, that
may be a risk of bigness.
But I think, actually,
if you follow
the job of doing something
that needs doing--
one of the companies I talk
about at the end of the book,
where I kind of try and
give some hopefulness
is the company Zipline.
So here's a company that's
using drones and on demand.
And they're not,
like, we're going
to be the Uber of dry cleaning.
They're, like, we're going
to be the Uber of blood
delivery in a country where the
leading cause of death in women
is postpartum hemorrhage.
There's no developed
hospital infrastructure.
There's bad roads.
But you can get a drone anywhere
in the country in 20 minutes.
And bang, that's astonishing.
That's like, wow, we can
solve a problem that's
a real problem with
this magical technology.
And guess what?
They're kind of not there
in that normal competitive
landscape, because
they've actually
found this green field
of opportunity, which
is solving a real problem.
And I think sure, the me,
too space, pretty crowded.
If you want to go, yeah, can
I make another social network?
Kind of hard, prob--
but there's another
piece to it, too.
Which I had a debate with
Reid Hoffman recently.
Because he's got a book
coming out on blitzscaling.
And I was, like, look, Reid.
You've got to
raise lots of money
because you have to grow
faster than your competitors,
so on and so forth.
It's still a winner takes all.
Somebody is going to win, and
somebody is going to lose.
And one of the things
I want to hear more
is how are these
platforms enabling
an ecosystem, which kind of goes
back to this sort of platform
thinking.
When you look at how
Google has been an enabler,
how YouTube is an enabler.
There's people getting
work from this.
And I think one of the
things that I think,
in a world of winner
takes all platforms,
the platforms themselves
have to think more
about how are we going to enable
a network of small business.
[APPLAUSE]